[Music]
58 seconds of damn logos we here music
playing get the play button is displayed
on the iPhone which would indicate that
nothing is actually playing also leave
t-rex out of this my purge playlist
purge playlist also third purge movie
continues to perpetuate the myth that at
least half of the population or twisted
murderers this is just one of a dozen
protests around our capital after
reports emerge claiming that the new
founding fathers had been using the
purge to help their own economic agenda
people don't give a shit about the
murder they give a shit about the
government spending less money on the
poor also an expositional news team they
uncover a story as long as it's
important to the plot also you brought
that up in the last movie rich people
are killing poorer people because of
economics and blah blah blah but is it
really helping how many people are dying
on purge night that really affect the
bottom line in a meaningful way whatever
happened to the Carmello guy from the
last movie did this franchise just
lazily replaced their african-american
revolutionary and think I wouldn't
notice also I thought the last movie
implied Carmelo was going to win this
thing why don't we have a third movie
again 18 years ago the local news
somehow got access to the footage from
the cold open of this movie this montage
isn't even trying anymore this is
clearly not the funeral for senator
Owens family seems like they just threw
in random funeral footage and hoped no
one would notice they clearly haven't
heard of cinema since that's going on
with this TV is this movie trying to
tell me the only difference between now
and 30 ish years into the future is that
we have a yearly murder holiday and
people watch TV in portrait mode this is
a warning to all of you who make videos
with your phone this way you keep this
up this is how we will all be watching
TV in 30 years you bastards is murder
our new image I thought it was and
everyone was explicit about it why is
everyone acting like she just said
something shocking celebrate the night
that saved this country from economic
ruin we have other ways maybe this is
the problem people like senator own have
only been whispering alternatives to
free murder for a night know what I said
she knows we need what's he so worried
about it's not purge night yet no one
gets killed on regular nights there has
been far less prize this is crap in his
defense according to the title cards of
the last two movies he's right also this
is supposed to be a presidential debate
you can't just interrupt your opponent
if you don't like what they're saying
even if it oh wait
so no income
people are killed during the purge than
anyone else I feel like after so many
years of this people would have gotten
smarter about defending themselves even
if they are low-income people like
setting up some deadly home alone traps
and buying easily acquired guns or just
plain leaving the country for 12 hours
she got some new titties but she got
some big-ass balls that's racist I put
you over to seven wait America now has
these new founding fathers that created
a murder holiday but we still have an
election system with an electoral
college you think that if everyone was
okay with the purge they'd be okay with
getting rid of the electoral system
altogether but you'd be wrong apparently
also the idea that they wouldn't engage
in election fraud is preposterous Looby
decides to utilize the rain machine on a
sunny day just how pointless is a
jump-scare when the purge hasn't even
started yet
also what an asshole the purge is
Halloween for a dog I'm pretty sure
Halloween is Halloween for adults also
how is this guy avoided being killed on
purge night this is movie saying his
booming mass business makes him one of
those elite curse who don't die during
the purge hell I got to a wealthy
stockbroker in the last movie surely
someone wants to kill this asshole
they're being called murder tourists
because we are clever anymore
we had to experience the purge this guy
heard that reporter from earlier say
people are arriving from Spain Denmark
South Africa so he decided to try all
those accents at the same time just to
cover his bases he touched me and I
scream rape um there are cameras in this
place right that's why he knew to go
back here in the first place not a great
threat but luckily somebody these two
thieving chicks respect is about to give
him back up that's a new record to me
it's convenient that Kimmy's friend
recognized who this is so that we could
know who this is even though it ends up
serving very little to the plot I want
men in there I feel like Leo's job is
mostly pointing at areas and saying he
wants men there men here men here
how many men could he possibly have
access to is anyone keeping track of how
many men he wants everywhere maybe this
is why the unemployment rate is so low
if I don't pay it by tomorrow
I have no purge coverage for his store a
question I never asked is how's the
purge affects small business owners also
if you're gonna be this blatantly evil
why even bother with a purge this kind
of tactic is of course super illegal but
if the insurance companies are really
behind all this purge madness then they
don't really have to worry about the law
or anything right I have no insurance I
screwed
Joe conveniently loses his insurance to
give him some vague motivation to
participate in purge night that not the
pot calling the kettle Brown Joe said
black with his mouth which would be the
correct euphemism but it's always said
Brown given the other offensive things
Joe will say later in this movie this
seems
odd place to censor even though this
brick house has these giant barricades
Joanna's team still felt the need to
have these guys standing outside in
plain view with no visible body armor as
we see this warning for the third time
in three movies I'm wondering if they're
ever going to explain what happens to
people who commit crimes outside a purge
night or if anyone's ever been convicted
of killing someone two minutes after the
7:00 a.m. deadline or if anyone's ever
driven from Nashville to Knoxville to
kill somebody and forgot about the time
zone change and for the first time since
its inception no one has been granted
special immunity from the purge also
they got rid of that pesky class 4
weapon rule I bet the weird guy who owns
a tank that I just made up is super
excited about that senator you should be
in the den she should also be wearing a
bulletproof vest and armed with a
flamethrower and grenade belt no one has
driven by and shot these people yet
Katniss Everdeen has definitely had
enough of that Capitol Bulls than is now
killing innocent but scary druggies on
the street Wow seriously a guillotine
how did they drag this thing in an alley
or did they buy the IKEA a new license
during their purge sale this guy is
driving incredibly well given that he is
wearing that mask
I mean think of the kind of work someone
has to put into scrolling purge in blood
on the Lincoln Memorial columns looks
great in a sadistic movie but who are
you gonna trust on purge night to steady
the ladder while you write the letters I
bet it was the guy who they hired to
make the movies theatrical poster also
Abe Lincoln is not a planet at the a pin
the scene Oh Suns going down
hey looks like someone needs our
services you know our services which
definitely you know but the unseen
audience doesn't it's like exposition
only more worthless it's purge night you
don't sneak up on black people
I wouldn't sneak up on anyone during
purge night I want you to go home and be
safe
yeah but the purge has already started
going home would be the most unsafe
thing he could do at this point
Lily expects me to believe that this
crazy girl took the time to meticulously
cover this car with Christmas lights and
then successfully drive it to this
location even though the windshield is
entirely covered with lights
these girls / the director were too
cheap to buy the Miley version of party
in the USA so they opted for the Kidz
Bop version oh no it's exactly who I
thought it was congratulations purge
election year on the most non dramatic
reveal in cinema history
and I'll want my candy bah this just
shows what a privileged life this girl
has after killing her parents who were
probably just being normal parents early
thought is to enact vengeance on the
shopkeep who wouldn't let her steal a
candy bar also are you gonna tell these
girls that their guns are obviously
plastic or should i that's the moment
where any normal insane teenager would
just turn into a whiny teenager again RT
took care of my mom and dad tonight
honestly I'm surprised a parricide among
angsty teenagers isn't a much larger
problem during the purge we've
experienced three purges and this is the
only example I can think of also good
luck with being an orphan
I'm sure that's way better than your mom
grounding you for a few weeks or Venus
Pit let's pretend for a second that
those guns are real and asked the
question where the hell did these girls
get these gold rhinestone aks that's
limited to have an armory in the future
as we then why doesn't approach calm
down dude so is Senator roan secretly
complying with the nffa s plot the
killer because it seems rather
convenient she'd want to have a private
conversation with Leo in the debt giving
these guys enough time to fiddle with
the cameras and I can only assume their
entire plan banks on Leo getting
distracted for a moment Leo the amazing
security expert doesn't notice the
timestamp is incorrect on this camera
white power
what's the electric company doing here
at this hour oh I'm coming outside noise
right because why stay here when you can
see all these different angles at once
and you could just go outside and have
limited visibility of your surroundings
this video is on a loop doesn't anyone
watch speed anymore
and there's a lot to teach us hey no not
that Bobby Leo's going to find out his
team's been compromised but somehow none
of the bad guys who also use these
radios understand that even though these
Klan SWAT team members had the draw on
Leo he was still able to stab both of
them without either of them shooting you
know the biggest problem with this
franchise is that it's just too subtle
this guy is a sniper rifle and this is
the best he can do
man it's too bad that I've had many you
left him the house isn't actually a bomb
oh it is excellent what happens he using
for this I connect bomb
why are they doing this right now they
just run the risk of getting killed
themselves and having their death truck
stolen is why I try and make your drone
inconspicuous when you can cover it with
multicolored lights that's how a man
drone I guess you can call the Chinese
factory where this drone was made a home
I'm sure somebody lives there it's
behind a veil 35 yards back 15 yards up
thrown is kind of cocky regarding her
distance estimating skills seriously
this crew of Bergers were just lying
around waiting for someone to come by
and that's dedication to the craft and
probably mighty born Charlie and Leo
both dropped their guard because movie
oh man they shot Lincoln this guy can't
catch a break
senator Joe is able to recognize the
senator from a distance without getting
a good look at her face China is the key
this is cute Marcos but I'm sure the
senator knows how the electoral college
that inexplicably still exists works I
know a little bit about first thing I
could help you every day in Juarez was
like medical school these thieving
whores managed to come back right when
Joe wasn't on the roof to notice them
also these girls meticulously decked out
a second car and Christmas lights I'm
gonna get that candy pop I hope Joe
learns a valuable lesson tonight
just let the crazy girl have the candy
bar and a call Joe plays the pronoun
game so that everybody has to ask who
the hell her is executive decision I'm
with Leo the senator thinks that she can
issue executive decisions even though
she isn't president yet I just want to
remind everyone that Kimmy wanting her
free candy bar is a major plot point in
this movie Kimmy Jimmy's friend don't
hear the loud band barreling toward them
Judy goes out of its way to show me
Kimmy's boots flying off yet here her
boots are completely still on loopy puts
an American Horror Story roanoke
commercial in the middle of itself how
did it get to this probably when murder
was legalized and endorsed by the
shadowy religious death cult that
controls the government
yeah damn conniving duplicitous crooked
fucking politicians I don't think I've
heard this much use of the word
cocksuckers buy a whole bunch of
different characters since the usual
suspects sounds like this is more a
screenwriter term than every characters
go-to word in the movie anybody hit okay
okay even though that giant machine gun
turned the van to Swiss cheese and the
only person who got hit was that kid I'd
already forgotten about booty pads run
time with slow-motion gang fight that I
really don't care about there was no way
they could have known me be in this band
does it matter they did what it sounds
like it very much matters like the
entire key to keeping the senator alive
kind of matters we get it leo you're a
badass but this is definitely a moment
when you're allowed to phone
and so the bullet that shot him when
they were escaping was also a tracking
device you movie yeah well I wish it
were that simple
y'all need to see this y'all need to see
this cliche was a whole bunch of Negroes
coming right this way we sittin up here
like a bucket of motherfuckin oh that's
like super racist but I guess it's okay
for this guy to say that I guess was a
Crip was well that was a risky flip of
the coin it's good they were the gang
that you thought they were even though
you had little indication of which gang
they were in the first place we're not
gonna hurt you
just help my fucking boy he's gonna die
was that their hope all along to get
this guy's kid on the van because before
that they all look like they were gonna
kill everybody in the van and then Joe
did some sort of crip whistle and
everybody shut the hell up now Joe is
probably regretting letting it slip that
he was a crypt we help you do something
for us to me it seems like the gang
really lucked out they now have the
opportunity to kill some white
supremacist call this is safe zone did
you come up with that all by yourself
these are the real victims of the purge
if all the dead people in the streets
could argue this point I'm sure they
would I've heard stories of tactics that
we will employ our first name Ron
chooses this moment right after she's
been rescued to question Dante's tactics
haven't mentioned this guy's orgy of
evidence that he's a racist yet I mean
two Confederate flags a swastika a bevy
of tattoos that probably represent white
guys are the bestest and that's not even
counting the white power on the back of
his uniform and head back to the deli
I'm sorry but you don't own a deli it's
a convenience store second of all why
the would you feel the need to go back
there if it was going to get looted that
ship has probably already sailed at this
point fine I'll Drive you Laney is
easily convinced instead of being
suspicious when anyone opens the door
why don't you try talking to Dante about
his facility in operation you'd get some
answers and we'd get some more
exposition what are you doing here if
this is such an important room to keep
people out of why is it so easy for any
asshole to walk into why do you have all
this oh this is our clues board it
allows someone who happens to snoop into
this room to slowly figure out our plot
to kill members of the nffa but our
government trucks I saw them on YouTube
from last year's purge someone watched
everything wrong with the purge anarchy
the ton on the original Church has been
closed up since the 50s but we've
reopened it we're gonna walk right
through there and into that church
without anybody even knowing why haven't
we done it already good question we had
to wait because hey does anyone know why
we waited to do this is it so the good
guys could uncover this plot
go Leo seems to assume there was one
booby trap and there can't possibly be a
second or third so they keep running
like they were before I can't win like
this it goes against everything that I
believe in this statement would make
sense if roans people were the ones that
concocted this plan to kill the minister
but it was a completely independent
group seems like Ron thinks that by not
having the power to stop Dante and his
men from killing the minister she's
somehow compromising her morals which is
disjointed that doesn't really make any
sense if they assassinate him he becomes
a martyr we lose that's a legit reason
let's go with that
did they really need to write in
back-to-back justifications for I guess
so even after getting t-boned while
everyone was standing in the back of the
van they all seemed to be mostly okay
also the klu klux walk clan was able to
find a senator and company with dumb
luck I guess
fruitless handgun shooting in an armored
truck again what's with the candles it
feels like big candle has some
incriminating photos of Hollywood
somewhere and it keeps cashing in like a
picture of Hollywood's O's not wearing a
bra or something I mean jeez get paid to
deliver the package not gift-wrapped
baldie waits until they are about done
tying her down before he says this well
CIN scour sanitize and sterilize our
souls tremendous alliteration there but
will you explain how you plan to sin
your souls and isn't that our job let us
begin
does it still count for all of you if
it's just one person up there killing
Alice do you know about the tunnel well
no need to explain that to a bunch of
guys who might be ready to kill me right
now they're just gonna have to admire my
dramatic balls also that's what you get
for leaving your master plan up on a
cork board Harmon will be the first
perjure of thee as is purge mask
tradition the creepiest dude gets to go
first fun fact about Herman he was
killed in last year's purge good news
Rome got the gag out of her oh wait
never mind it's quite convenient for our
heroes that warns is the slowest throat
slitter in existence giving them ample
time to set up and take the shot no one
in the balcony is getting shot at even
though they all have basically no cover
especially Lanie and they were all saved
by bulletproof fuse
was that it was bullets oh come on we
all know this guy would be a sniveling
coward if he was actually in the
situation but who needs
multi-dimensional characters right
I like black people but angle it Josh
shoot these white folks Joe inexplicably
makes it about race for the seventh or
eighth time I am well still requires the
votes of the people in the electoral
college I mean great cinema and
everything but there's not much you can
do about it what about these people the
purge must be coming to an end soon
right why not just leave them there and
then come back for them when it's not as
murdery outside better yet everyone
stays put until 7:00 that really so hard
leo is about to successfully fight this
guy even though he would shot the
shoulder and has lost a lot of blood
there's anything that purge franchise
has taught me it's a bullet to the
shoulder really isn't all that bad
orals vest may be bulletproof but it's
not even a tiny little knife proof the
nffa decided to keep the election system
mostly intact but move the day we vote
from November 8th to May 26th because
you know a nation reborn movie somehow
makes the state of Tennessee a blue
state even though nearly all of its
southeastern brethren accept South
Carolina are red also Vermont and Maine
are staunch red states in this reality
the fuck that the senator has also taken
Florida how nice she took Marcoses
advice win more electoral votes than
your opponent also despite Marcos being
proven right here the problem is
according to this map she was already
way over 270 electoral votes before
Florida so Florida's role in the
election year can go itself and ff8
supporters are reacting violently to
this defeat oh god I hope this movie
isn't predicting the future
it is a disaster
mom's showing up Creole gumbo you just
be careful key with all that hope coz it
can be a bad thing
hope can drive a man insane Jesus for
dropping a building on my face they come
[Music]
they want the impossible a wrong kid
died mister I'm sorry I know you do it
Dixon yeah you can call me Josh used to
call me crazy Joe
well now they can call me Batman funny
mom Lonnie MA
you